[Musique]
les anges de la télé réalité émission
diffusée sur nrj12 depuis 2011 dans
laquelle d'anciens candidats de télé
réalité cohabitent dans une villa le
tournage de la saison 13 aurait dû
débuter ces prochains jours à la réunion
mais trois des candidats dont neruda à
27 ans sept cent trente neuf mille
abonnés sur son compte instagram et son
petit ami riccardo 28 ans 6 178 milles
abonnés sur instagram que l'on peut voir
dans cette charmante vidéo dépassé les
bornes commence dans le restaurant de
l'hôtel le créolia alors que joé bédier
le maire en question est attablé avec sa
famille en train de déjeuner à côté de
candidats de l'émission un membre de la
production vient prendre à partie le
maire de la ville
l'accusant d'avoir pris des photos d'eux
avec son téléphone portable très vite le
ton monte
et s'il croit d'abord à une blague les
candidats insistent pour voir les
téléphones portables de tous les membres
de sa famille un refus qui aurait mis
hors d'eux les candidats je me rends
compte et que c'est une c'est une
c'est une table et je lui dis mais
madame dégager de là je suis en famille
je ne vais plus pouvoir à table certains
ont pu filmer donc on ne voit pas tout
sur cette vidéo amateur mais les cris
vont peut-être vous donner une petite
les deux candidats s'en serait pris
physiquement à plusieurs clients d'un
hôtel restaurant de saint denis dont
jouer bédié le maire de saint-andré
qu'on a entendu plus tôt mais aussi à sa
famille et c'est là qu'elle monte le ton
et tous et ses hommes sont venus tatoué
du coup jusqu'aux pieds torse nu et une
chance ils nous ont sauté dessus parce
qu'ils croyaient en photo énormément de
de violence ils ont été évidemment
interpellé les trois ricardo sa campagne
neruda et pauline la la nounou juste
avant d'être entendu en garde à vue le
candidat ricardo avait l'air quand même
assez détendu à son balcon et faisait un
même des signes aux caméras vous le
voyez depuis lui et sa compagne ont été
remises en liberté mais cette
altercation et monter jusqu aux oreilles
du ministre d outre-mer sébastien
lecornu qui s'est quand même fendu d'un
tweet pour dénoncer des actes
inadmissibles
non
rien de rien
je ne regrette rien
là non
à
rien de rien
non
la chanson entière c'est ça on a touché
à la société bayonnaise
on a tous chers à notre vivre ensemble
et ces gens ne peuvent pas venir comme
cela et je crois toujours un terrain
conquis
oui ils tancent que tout est permis ces
personnes qui passent à la télé qui
passa ouaki par dompter les pays qui
cassent les meubles
je prends toi qui vient va être quoi
cassé une patte à un canard
ni 3 d'ailleurs non pour des raisons de
réduction de budget au sein de
télévision nous allons réaliser ce
jingle à la firme en a la bouche c'est
parti viens voir ja voir le docteur nom
et pape s'est vraiment bien reconnaît le
budget s'il vous plaît à la demande
générale elle est en tout cas ça fait un
an
aujourd'hui jour pour jour que le
premier morts officiels chinois du
coronavirus a été recensé un an plus
tard la chine a à nouveau coupée du
monde deux de ces villes après une
résurgence des contaminations ça fait 11
millions de personnes qui sont isolées
et des campagnes de dépistage massives
sont en cours dominique est à la
recherche du mascara qui lui fera des
yeux de biche
depuis qu'elle porte un masque elle mise
tout sur le regard je mets plus de jeu
mais plus de rouges à lèvres parce que
ça sert à rien ça se voit pas et puis
plus de plus de blush sur les sur les
joues comme elle 46 % des françaises
déclaré en juillet dernier - se
maquiller depuis le confinement en fait
au mois de janvier choix jean médecin et
je suis monté sur la bouche
j'avais 68 kilos de trop sur ma balle en
cinq ans la première chose qu elle dit
en gros je mangeais une personne
j'étais pas pesé depuis combien de temps
avant d'acheter médecin 90 non tu sais
combien 120 moi je suis rappelé que je
fais des roses par moins 10 secondes
moi dans la vie je ne fume pas parce que
pour moi la cigarette c'est comme la
pipe
j'aime pas le goût mais bon c'est voilà
je pouvais pas faire plus chic que cette
photo florilège on a on a observé une
baisse de 30% dans nos achats de rouge à
lèvres dans les achats des clients de
rouge à lèvres une baisse de 20% au
niveau du teint on vend plus de pointe
et de maquillage avant le confinement
42% des femmes se maquillent et tous les
jours depuis elles ne sont plus que 21 %
une tendance qui touche davantage les
femmes de moins de 30 ans qu'est ce qui
pèse le plus aujourd'hui mon ventre et
blablate s'étaient battus marche bleue
plate d'adhérents joue pas et quand
mario wii
j'aime pas c'est pas très seyant en même
temps tu sais sa besace partout on en
rigole mais passe contre femmes on peut
se dire qu'on ait bel amoureux se voit
là il faut pas hésiter mais il faut pas
hésiter à dire aux gens qu'ils sont
beaux mais même à soi même
j'avais prévu bien sûr bruno vous êtes
beau j'aimerais tellement vous retourner
le compliment mais après ça va c'est
faux marchés
parce qu'on a du gaz en fait dans le
ventre le gaz quand à insulter faut et
il n est pas si je vais pas je suis trop
timide une fin d'activité c'est
d'avancer quand on entend de tous en
tout cas pas une mode est venu bien sur
route péter substantif paie bien vrai
pas résister
sinon il y avait guère oui c'est ça
c'est ça c'est oui bien sûr faire du ski
en plein coeur de la capitale espagnole
en temps normal la circulation est très
dense sur cette avenue
depuis hier elle s'est transformée en
piste de ski et de luge jeunes ou vieux
s'amuse avec la neige certains avec
maladresse d'autres véritables pros
voici encore une preuve du dérèglement
climatique
en grèce c'est totalement inverse le
pays connaît une vague de chaleur mais
vraiment avec des pointes en effet des
températures jusqu'à 28 degrés hier un
tank et inciter les grecs à se relâcher
alors que le pays est confiné les
habitants ont investi les plages ils se
sont rendus en masse au bord de la mer
et dans les parcs des températures
habituelles à cette période de l'année
en grâce et environ 15 degrés c'est à
dire moitié moi je vous souhaite à
toutes et à tous
bon bon
[Musique]